All right.
You're done.
Let's talk about how I solved this one.
Let's take a look at the sunshine
service you just wrote.
To begin with, it's useful to have
some constants, a log tag, so
we can actually see
how it's functioning.
And most importantly,
this location query extra.
We use this location query extra
to pass the location query.
Into our Intents service.
In onHandleIntent, we actually put
the code that we had in do in background
in our fetch weather task.
However, as you can see the only
parameter we get is an intent.
So we pull the location
query out of a stringExtra.
Using the location query extra string.
We can copy the rest of the code
from fetch weather task here
because intent service also
creates a helper thread for
us to run code on,
similar to what a string task does.
Note that we also fix up all of
the code that refers to m context.
As a service, also has its own context.
The final thing we do,
is call our service from update weather,
with in forecast fragment.
We simply put an extra for
the location query,
instead of using it as a parameter.
And then start the service.
Then we can delete the fetch weather
task, and its associated test.